[Music]
my next guest is a comedian who's making
her television stand-up debut with us
here tonight and his new album sweet
beth will be available soon please
welcome to very funny beth stelling
thank you
i recently moved from illinois
to california and i think that you would
be hard-pressed to find anybody here
tonight who's done something that brave
but i did
and i just got some news from my sister
back home
she and her boyfriend
accidentally planned a baby
she was telling me she's only eating
like 300 more calories a day to
accommodate the life form growing inside
her bod which blows my mind
because i consume at least a thousand
more calories during a pregnancy scare
in fact i just went out and got an iud
no sir not a urinary tract infection
it's an intrauterine device in its birth
control last five years goes right in
your uterus it's the only time i'll say
uterus
said it again
so i went in for my consultation and the
lady was like bath
everything looks good
fun fact didn't know if you knew this
but your uterus
is actually tilted
backwards did you know that
and i was like okay
so what you're telling me is even my
uterus is like
we're good
i biked everywhere in chicago so when i
got here to la i thought hey i can ride
my bike here
until i realize that you guys
hate that
i would ride through every single winter
in chicago and one day i was all bundled
up for the cold and i pulled up to a
stop sign and some old man must have
been waiting for the bus because he
leans over to me and he goes excuse me
sir
is the bus coming
and i was like
i'm a girl
and then i rode away
[Music]
so the rest of the winter i was just
wearing my bra on the outside of my [ __ ]
biking has been good for me helped me
lose a little bit of weight which is
nice because i was getting real tired of
people just getting a boner for my
personality
[Music]
i had originally gained the weight
because i would find myself walking over
to cvs
uh for dinner
i love sweets like chocolate cookies
candy people call me sweet beth
one person calls me that so
it was me i just did it
when you check out at a cvs there's like
tons of lady mags up front at the
checkout that's an abbreviation for lady
magazines
and no matter what time of year it is
they will always say something like get
your body bikini ready
in that voice and i just
just slid those hostess cupcakes right
over the counter and i was like i think
i can settle for being tankini with some
ruffles
ready
my favorite reality television show to
watch is the bachelor i like watching it
and waiting until it gets down to like
the final two crazy bag women
that are vying for this one man's love
on national television uh just so i can
hear one of the girls say something like
in a million years
would i have ever imagined
falling in love this hard
are this fast
on national tele
i'm like ready to spend forever with
baton
because i want to be there you know and
be like whoa hey gal listen up
uh if i were taking free helicopter
rides horseback riding on the beach in
tahiti and having candle dinners on a
private island in the bahamas
i could probably fall in love with my
brother
and he's 16. so that's it
thank you guys so much
that was great thank you that was fun
thank you so much
great job best selling very funny